Film Courage: How hard is it
to write an emotional scene?
Jason Satterlund, Filmmaker: For me personally
well I should say for me personally it's
not as hard and I only say that because
I tend to be very intuitive in my writing
process and a lot of times when I'm writing
I'm feeling it a lot more than other people are
that as an intuitive kind of person
I just have very deep emotions and
they just come out really easily and
it's very easy to spill it on the page
but the challenge for me is actually
getting the audience to feel the same way
so on I'm about to say unfortunately
it comes down to structure it's really
if you really want to pull out
emotion it's it has less to do with
depth as it has to do with the structure of
your scene because the structures walk is gonna
the structure is your frame of your house but the
emotion is the furniture within it so without that
structure of the house you're just going to have
furniture sitting in the middle of a field it's
just gonna feel weird it's going to even if the
actor's bringing it it's still going to be kind of
in this weird nebulous space it's just not really
much of anything but with the structure it's what
contains everything it's super vital it get back
gets back to the same kind of stuff we were just
talking about about the importance of goals and
stakes and all kinds of things like that like
if you wanna I could very easily write
out an emotional scene about someone
who lost their father like you could have
someone oh I miss dad and he passed away
and if you just tuned in and watched the one scene
and the actress does a great performance pulling
that out yeah it might be compelling but it's
not going to have the impact that you that you
want it to have unless you understand more about
why dad's loss was so important right where what
that relationship was like that's all that's all
the structure of backstory and context that you
need to set up so that when we get to emotional
scene it it's paying off in the way that you mean
for it to otherwise it's just one character
spouting off and just kind of being emotional
Denzel Washington could pull that off but even
then if it doesn't have forward direction to it
it's just not going to land the way you hope and
this happens a lot as in my personal Journey as a
screenwriter where I'm just like so feeling these
scenes that I've written and then other people
read and go yeah this wasn't quite landing ah
it's so yeah what the guy's pouring his heart out
on paper yeah it's because there's the guy's all
he's doing is pouring his hot out on paper without
going anywhere he's just wallowing and there's
no point there's no direction there's there's
do it's so much more in the movie Breaking Bad or
a movie the pilot episode of Breaking Bad there's
a fantastic scene in there where Walter White if
you've seen this show he he starts off as this
very vanilla spineless guy and you watch him take
this journey where you learn that he's got cancer
he's gonna die he realizes his life is over he
realizes he's got no savings to save his family
and then through all this he's realizing he's a
chemistry teacher and he knows about science and
all this stuff and he sees that criminals who sell
math make a lot of money and he sees oh there's
a way for me to make a lot of money right so he's
watching his journey going through all these steps
and there's this great scene right after he's
bought all the equipment he's decided he's going
to cook meth and he's this very introverted
character and Jesse comes up to him and says
this isn't how I remember you at all
like like at all like you you were
this kind of douche like the just this
lame teacher that just didn't seem like
he cared about anything and all of
a sudden you just have this passion
what is it what happened and I think the
performance of the scene was very powerful Walter
White looks at him he says I'm awake it's so
simple but it carries so much of a punch because
you had all of this really good setup framework
of his life and you watch how his life is like
teak things are falling apart he's dying he's not
going to leave anything in this world and you see
him wake up and it carries the emotional impact
because we saw it we experienced it all with him
and then boom you're hit with it around that scene
I that's what makes emotional scenes work now
is it easy to do I don't think it's easy to do
I think it takes a lot of practice and hard work
but now if someone else could do all that work
for me and set all that up and then write in the
emotional scene by itself it's super easy for me
because I think that way but yeah the challenge
is is all the context so an emotional scene
where you're just like bleeding in front of
the audience doesn't work unless there's a setup
I mean it could work I just don't think it's
it's not going to carry the same punch that you
want it to unless they know why they're feeling
this way why this is such a big moment if I mean
and think of it like if if there is a character
that you're following in a movie or show and all
they do is that they're constantly emotional it's
just a late it's a chore to watch you don't
want to see it it's too much have you ever
seen a movie that's just so sad and such a drag
that you don't actually want to watch it again
that's the kind of feeling you're gonna get you
kind of need the journey you need the setup you
need the context you need the gold the stakes
and all that to so that once that character
does get to that emotional break you're in your
you want you're on the journey right with them
so yes it could be powerful on its own and those
are the odd the clips we see from the Oscars
the best first nominee for Academy Award is
Jared Leto and you see the emotional scene
that's fine for a minute but it's not going to
carry the punch unless you see the hole thing I
don't think did you watch the Queen's Gambit yeah
excellent did you like it yes very much and this
what I've took from that is that her circumstances
were showing us this build up but did she really
have any full did she ever feel sorry for herself
it felt like she didn't and she just turned it all
into the chess matches that's where she took any
type of self-pity or whatever was beating whoever
it was that she wanted to be that's a good point
that's a good point it's I actually think it's
hard to watch shows where characters feel sorry
for themselves it's they're out there I can't
think of one an example at the top of my head but
I think it's hard harder to watch you want to see
a character take their terrible background and
turn it into something make it their power that's
what that's exciting to watch like the Queen's
Gambit this little girl raise an orphan suddenly
becomes a chess genius oh I'm in like that's
awesome like because she the it's a classic
underdog story sure if Rocky all did nothing but
whine about his poor background and how he never
got a chance as a boxer and that's the end it
would be hard to watch but he he goes the distance
with Apollo Creed and we're like yeah so yeah
what was one of the first films to make you cry oh
I have what the first film that made me cry I
tell you the one that had the biggest impact
on me this is such a weird one but it was The
Prince of Tides I don't know if you've ever
seen that film but it is a gut wrencher
I'm sure that I got emotional in films
prior to that but that one for some reason really
stands out because it deals with this guy kind of
coming to terms with his very very tragic past
and I will say that for me emotions were always
very much a struggle because they I always
looked at them as something that was weak
which is a problem for a director and someone
who tells stories in my household growing
up showing the showing of vulnerability and
emotion was dangerous it's just not something
that you could do and at and I do remember as
I watched films getting pulled in emotionally
whether it was sadness tears or Terror
those two deep vulnerability things
were stuff that I tried not to show and tried
very hard to fight it's part of what made me
a filmmaker because when I would feel terrified
or really sad I would pull myself out and look
at the way the film was constructed started
looking at oh let me oh it's just an actor
sitting there and there's a director talking to
them and oh look at the interesting lighting I
would purposely start to deconstruct the film
to pull myself out of the entire experience
it took me many many years to really become
comfortable with just my own emotions
I don't know why Prince of Tides stands if
you've ever seen that film it's a fairy it's
Barbra Streisand and Nick Nolte and he's this
kind of big man and he's he ends up like just
sobbing and breaking down that film really hit
me hard because I think it was very similar
to my own life that's probably why it stands
out to me so much it's one that just boom but
emotions are very key to the the business that
we're in and I think it's really important to
be comfortable with that especially as a director
because I need to be I'm asking actors to do that
and I want to be pulled in by that right I'm
asking audiences to be pulled in by those same
emotions well then what am I doing trying to fight
it all the time and act like I don't feel anything
I maybe I'm in the wrong business if
that's how I'm approaching all of this
learning how to be okay with expressing emotions
I mean it's taken me a long time but I've gotten
to a point now where I can be on set talking
to an actor and they're just dumping out how
they feel and it's very they're in this very
broken place we're trying to capture that
and I am with them because I want to show
them it's okay so I oftentimes will be
crying with them so sometimes that will
happen but I'm also trying to talk to my DP
and the Wardrobe person in between all of this
so I have to be comfortable enough while I'm in
this kind of broken spot with them to turn to my
DP while I'm all right so let's grab the 85 and
then when we go on this moment but like not be for
years and years and years I struggled with that
position of like ah they're gonna think I'm ugh
what a wuss I had to like really learn to let that
go it helps the entire room when you can embrace
it and just be okay with it it will I feel like it
will be imprinted on the DNA of the film if you're
okay with it it'll help pull the audience in too
some people are much easier with that than others
I I struggle with it for many many years but
yeah so Prince of time it's a tough watch
okay I'll have to go back and look at that
it's an obscure one it's funny that that's
the one that pops into my mind is the first
but yeah I remember watching that one it's
like oh it's it's a good movie directed by
Barbra Streisand and she's in it with Nick
Nolte yeah wow yeah how many movies can
you name off the top of your head that if
you saw them today they would make you cry
oh above my head it's gonna sound so funny jaws
and I tell you why Jaws in the scene when the
little boy is mimicking his dad what I'm talking
about where he's he's having a tough day and
and he's just sitting there thinking and the
other boys at the table and he's like imitating
his father and he realizes his son is copying
him and they're going back and forth doing all
these it's just it's just a beautiful moment and
in the end Roy Scheider leans over to the boy and
says give me a kiss and the kid goes why because
because I need it ah that scene gets me every time
and I think it's that definitely like father-son
scenes like the second Guardians of the Galaxy
movie when he wasn't he may have been
your daddy but he may have been your
father but he wasn't your daddy Yondu no oh I'm
just a mess anything that deals with Father and
Son coming together and having this body usually
really gets me I who off the top of my head
oh man I'm going to think of it like soon
as the camera stops and be like oh this one
and this one and this one and this one Coda I
just watched coded that one got me that was if
you're familiar with it stands for children
of deaf adults and it's about a deaf family
and the daughter is can hear the rest
of the family cannot and she wants to do
music It's A Beautiful film Emily gets me
quite a bit it's just this beautiful love
story about her finding love and it's
just so it's just such a wonderful film
I'm sure I'll be able to think more
later but yeah and I get more comfortable
with it as I get older of just like being
vulnerable to a lot of that stuff but yeah.